file storage is a critical need for many
enterprise applications and workloads
but file storage is about more than just
disk space it's about finding a solution
that is
fast consistent scalable and still
simple to use
[Music]
some of the most common use cases for
file storage in
enterprise applications are media
rendering
data analytics and managing shared
content
these complex situations require
flexible and scalable solutions
plenty of us have heard it before
storage is cheap
but with needs growing exponentially to
fit use cases like these
companies want flexibility to scale on
demand
and meet specific performance needs of
their application
and user demands and now that companies
are turning to cloud computing solutions
for applications
and for their infrastructure there's a
growing demand for cloud-based file
systems
to meet the needs of customers looking
for a fully managed cloud-based storage
product
google offers file store
file store gives users a simple native
experience for standing up managed
network attached storage
or nas for their compute engine and
google kubernetes engine instances
we also rely on file storage partners
such as netapp
and dell emc isilon today we're going to
show you how to quickly configure and
attach your file system to a compute
instance
say we have an intensive workload and
many clients and high throughput
is critical to begin i'll name my
instance
for example performance test
next i have to select a service tier
since i need a high performance
application with many connected clients
i'll go with high scale for help picking
the tier that's right for you
you can check out the comparison table
the storage type for high scale is ssd
which works for me and with basic i
would also have the option of hdd
i'll keep capacity at 60 terabytes and
can always scale up or down when needed
without any service interruption
as i specify different capacities i can
check the calculator for cost and
performance estimates
now i have to choose a location since my
clients are located in us
central 1 the default location is
perfect
i can set a specific zone or let the
deployment decide for me
next i'll select the network used by my
clients so they'll be able to access
this file system
once i have a network i'll allocate an
ip range or let the service do this for
me
the file system mount point ip address
will be selected from this range
next i'll give my share a name dcc
this will be represented in the mount
location later even though i can grant
or restrict access to my file system
through ipb-based controls
i'll leave it open for now and now i'm
ready to create my instance
once it's ready i can see all my
instance details and copy the mount
point string
now i'll ssh into a client vm i already
created and mount my file system using
the mount point i copied earlier to
slash mnt directory
let's run some loads and take a look at
the performance
i'm starting with 256 clients performing
simultaneously with intensive iops
you can see the clients are building
their working set
and here you can see the latency
leveling off at 10 milliseconds
and iops reaching 150 000 since my
clients are saturating the instance
i need higher performance and more
capacity so i'm going to scale up my
instance from 60 terabytes to 320
terabytes
after my instance scales up you can see
the graph start to change
here the latency graph drops showing
much lower latency
and the iops graph is climbing to 600
000 iops
as we'd expect the total throughput is
also growing accordingly
for anyone that's ever managed their own
storage and panicked because they needed
to slap another
physical drive in a server before they
ran out of space this was pretty
exciting
today we saw how google cloud's file
storage is used to migrate traditional
applications
modernize existing applications with
kubernetes and scale to meet the
performance demands of big compute
workloads
from media rendering to genomics
processing google's file storage can
meet the needs of business critical
workloads
thanks for joining us and please check
out our website and documentation to
learn
even more about file store